millions of Americans enjoy playing golf
but golf courses are not known to be
environmentally friendly they demand a
lot of fresh water fertilizers and
herbicides to keep them looking green
that's true of most golf courses but
let's look at one that is trying
something different this is the miami
beach golf club the grass used here is
called seashore paspalum it's the most
environmentally friendly graphs in the
world dr. Ron Duncan is a turf
researcher at the University of Georgia
and the leading expert on seashore
paspalum and environmentally friendly
from the standpoint that you can save
the potable water use for the human side
and utilize all other alternative water
sources like brackish water our water
out of sewage plants to irrigate this
grass also you have a reduced management
budget because it requires about half
the fertilizers that you normally use on
other grasses also you can save pawn
pesticide use what makes seashore
paspalum so special is that it can
survive and thrive in high salt
environments so brackish water or
partially salty water can be used to
irrigate this grass this translates into
big savings for the golf course we
estimate at this point we're going to
reduce our dependency on freshwater by
about 65 to 75 percent that'll save us
somewhere in the range of 175 to two
hundred thousand dollars annually and on
freshwater Steve forest is the architect
who designed this golf course he says
seashore paspalum has other advantages
besides being environmentally friendly
this grass are able to provide a
striking pattern and of like you would
see on a football field or if you were
vacuuming your carpet this grass is also
green or darker green and texture so you
can again have different contrasts in
color throughout the golf course which
is desirable from an architectural
standpoint of view
so do golfers rate seashore paspalum as
a birdie or a bogey I would definitely
come back and I was very impressed with
it we've came down to play three rounds
and we played at three different courses
and this is by far the best the end use
is here it's not in my research plots
it's not at the University of Georgia
it's it's where it's going to be used
and the acceptance of the golfers now
and in various people trying this grass
in a lot of different areas that's the
pleasure that I'm getting seashore
paspalum appears to be a green solution
that's par for the course